.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Dynamische Musik *
* Triumphale Musik *
Die FIFA
ist eine richtige Geldmaschine.
The winner is Qatar!
(Beni Thurnheer) Katar,
das ist eine Riesenüberraschung.
Katar 22 - eine Wahl überschattet
von Korruptionsvorwürfen.
Voilà, c'est ici.
In US-Akten finden wir
brisante Aussagen eines Kronzeugen.
Wir wissen von Korruptionsvorwürfen
dank eines Kronzeugen,
der darüber
detailliert ausgesagt hat.
Und wir stellen fest:
Seine Aussagen über Katar-Korruption
tauchen in einem Urteil
der FIFA-Ethikkommission auf.
Niemand spricht über Korruption.
Ich bin absolut nicht bestechlich.
Lassen Sie mich festhalten:
Der Vertrauensmissbrauch
ist empörend,
das Ausmass der Korruption
unvorstellbar.
Verhaftungen
im Zürcher Nobelhotel Baur au Lac.
Die FIFA-Affäre platzt
vor den Augen der Öffentlichkeit.
Several senior FIFA officials
on corruption charges.
Un escándalo de corrupción
de la FIFA ...
Die Amerikaner machten das,
was sie gut können:
Sie nahmen auch
die Spur des Geldes auf.
Die Schweiz
gerät in den Strudel der FIFA-Affäre.
Der Anfang
eines riesigen Justizskandals -
im Fokus der Bundesanwalt.
It's a huge case.
Es ist ein sehr grosser Fall
für die Bundesanwaltschaft.
It's one of the biggest cases
I've ever seen.
Ich werde alles dafür tun, dass uns
dieser Fall nicht überfordert.
Im Ausland entstand der Eindruck,
dass die Schweizer Justiz unfähig
oder nicht willens ist,
um diese heiklen
und komplexen Verfahren aufzudecken.
Es ist einfach
unendlich kompliziert.
(Hansjürg Zumstein) Das sind
über 1'000 Seiten Protokoll.
US-Gerichtsprotokolle,
Urteile, interne Unterlagen.
Und wir finden
auch einen Bundesgerichtsentscheid,
der sich als sehr aufschlussreich
erweisen wird.
Wer aber wusste in der FIFA
von diesen Hinweisen
über gekaufte Stimmen?
Und weshalb
hat die FIFA nicht gehandelt?
In meinen 30 Jahren als
SRF-Journalist spürte ich noch nie
so viel Gegenwind
wie bei dieser FIFA-Recherche.
Wir kontaktieren
den FIFA-Präsidenten Gianni Infantino
und wollen Antworten
auf unsere Fragen.
Wir, ein SRG-Journalistenteam,
recherchieren zu den
Korruptionsvorwürfe rund um Katar.
Wir alle haben Erfahrungen
in diesen Themengebieten.
Der Westschweizer Journalist
Ludovic Rocchi
drehte über Gianni Infantino
einen Dokumentarfilm.
Seine Interviewanfrage
lehnte der FIFA-Präsident damals ab.
Gianni Infantino ist zum besten
Verkäufer der WM in Katar geworden.
Er beherrscht die Kommunikation
und kontrolliert sie.
Bittet man ihn um ein Interview
und er weiss,
dass kritische Fragen kommen,
lehnt er in der Regel ab.
(Gianni Infantino) The World Cup
Qatar in a few months,
the first World Cup
in the Arab world.
* Dynamische Musik *
Es ist eine unglaubliche Geschichte.
Was hier entstanden ist und ent-
wickelt wurde, ist grossartig, toll!
Eine WM der Superlative.
Acht Stadien neu gebaut,
eine Investition
von geschätzten 220 Mrd. ¤.
(Kommentator) Please welcome ...
(Sascha Ruefer)
FIFA-Präsident Gianni Infantino.
This World Cup will simply be
the best World Cup ever.
Now it's getting serious.
Please, Your Highness.
Thank you, Mr President.
Ich bin stolz und glücklich darüber,
dass die Welt Katar sehen wird.
Thank you.
Gianni Infantino geht sehr weit
mit seinen Bemühungen,
die WM in Katar zu propagieren.
Er zog mit seiner Familie sogar
nach Katar - offiziell, so die FIFA,
damit er näher
beim WM-Organisationskomitee sei.
Aber wir wissen,
dass bis heute kein FIFA-Präsident,
also z.B. Herr Blatter,
seinen Wohnsitz wegen einer WM
nach Südafrika
oder nach Deutschland verlegt hat.
Katar,
ein Wüstenstaat am Persischen Golf.
Ein Viertel so gross wie die Schweiz.
Wegen den hohen Temperaturen
findet die WM im Winter statt.
Alles klimaneutral, betont Katar.
Ein Wüstenstaat
ohne grosse Fussballtradition
organisiert eine Fussball-WM.
Das Land schwimmt im Geld.
Die wichtigsten Einnahmequellen:
Erdöl und v.a. Erdgas.
Katar - eine Monarchie
mit dem Emir an der Spitze.
* Er spricht arabisch. *
Er befiehlt, langwierige
Bewilligungsverfahren gibt es keine.
Frauen sind kaum sichtbar,
denn das katarische Gesetz
beruht auf der Scharia.
90 % der Bewohner sind nicht Katarer.
Es sind Arbeitsmigranten -
Bauarbeiter, Hausangestellte.
Ihre Rechte sind eingeschränkt.
Gegen aussen
gibt sich das Land fortschrittlich.
... and shouted: "Goal!"
Endlich ist der Tag da:
ein arabischer Gastgeber für die WM.
Qatar is ready for game.
Die WM-Vergabe an Katar -
zweifelhafter Höhepunkt
einer umstrittenen FIFA-Geschichte.
The winner is Qatar.
Die Wahl von Katar im Jahr 2010
hat für die FIFA in gewisser Weise
den heutigen Ärger verursacht.
Wie ist es dazu gekommen?
Wir tauchen ein
in die Geschichte der FIFA.
Wir studieren Akten,
Gerichtsunterlagen, Protokolle.
Und wir ordnen alles chronologisch.
Scheinbar harmlose Treffen erhalten
plötzlich eine neue Bedeutung.
Der lange Schatten der Korruption.
Mittendrin: drei Fussballpräsidenten
im Kampf um die Macht.
Sepp Blatter ...
... Michel Platini
und Gianni Infantino.
Dieses Trio, ein fatales Trio -
Blatter, Infantino, Platini.
Die drei Männer sprechen heute
nicht mehr miteinander
und beschuldigen sich gegenseitig
des Komplotts.
Die FIFA -
organisiert als Verein
mit Hauptsitz in Zürich.
4,7 Mrd. Fr.
budgetierte Einnahmen im Jahr 2022.
Alle Einnahmen würden zurück in den
Fussball fliessen, betont die FIFA.
Eine Non-Profit-Organisation.
TV-Screens im FIFA-Museum.
* Heroische Musik *
* Jubel *
Fussball fasziniert die ganze Welt.
Ein Milliardengeschäft -
auch dank den FIFA-
Weltmeisterschaften alle vier Jahre.
Das Milliardengeschäft
beginnt mit Sepp Blatter.
Jahrelang prägt er die FIFA.
17 Jahre lang als Generalsekretär
und weitere 17 als Präsident.
* Lockere Swing-Musik *
Sepp Blatter - Arbeiterkind,
katholisch, aufgewachsen im Wallis.
In seiner Jugend
leidenschaftlicher Fussballspieler.
Offizierskarriere,
Wirtschaftsstudium.
Dann Einstieg
ins professionelle Sportgeschäft.
Dreimal verheiratet,
dreimal geschieden.
Merci.
Meine Verlobte oder meine Lebens...
Meine Verlobte ist die FIFA.
* Dynamische Musik *
Der Neid deiner Mitmenschen
ist Gradmesser deines Erfolgs.
Sein Vorgänger heisst João Havelange,
hier rechts im Bild.
(Hansjürg Zumstein)
Ihr Mentor und Vorgänger
sagte irgendwann mal zu Ihnen:
"Sepp, tu as créé un monstre."
Mit der FIFA.
Ja gut ...
"Tu as créé un monstre" ...
Plötzlich wurde der Fussball
eine wirtschaftliche Kraft.
Es war so viel Geld
in der FIFA drin.
Nicht nur in der FIFA selber,
auf der ganzen Welt.
Als diese Summe
ins Unendliche stieg,
erhielten wir automatisch
auch eine politische Dimension.
Das meinte João Havelange mit:
"Maintenant, tu as créé un monstre."
Jetzt kommen noch
die Politiker dazu.
Begonnen hat das Monster in Paris.
Im Mai 1998
kandiert Blatter als FIFA-Präsident.
Herr Blatter,
Champs Élysées, Paris -
wie sieht es aus mit Ihrer
Sportpolitik der letzten Wochen?
Mein Fokus lag
auf Besuchen in Afrika, Südafrika.
Dort gibt es ganz klare Ja-Stimmen
für die Zukunft des Fussballs.
Aber insbesondere sprechen die
Afrikaner das Thema Weltcup 2006 an.
Sie wissen, dass daraus nichts wird,
wenn sie für Johansson stimmen.
So nebenbei verspricht Blatter
Südafrika bereits die WM.
Und er wird das Versprechen
später auch einlösen.
Wie bringen Sie die Leute dazu,
für Sie zu stimmen?
Mein Vorteil ist,
dass ich kommunikativ bin.
Ich verstehe es, mit ihnen zu
sprechen, und zwar in ihrer Sprache.
Blatter umgibt sich in Paris
mit zahlreichen Stars.
Seine Aussenseiterkandidatur
erhält so zusätzlichen Rückhalt.
Nous avons annoncé officiellement
ma candidature aujourd'hui à Paris.
Wahlhelfer ist Michel Platini -
einst französischer
Spitzenfussballer,
jetzt
erfolgreicher Fussballfunktionär.
Comment ça va?
- Très bien.
Diese Freundschaft
wird den beiden 17 Jahre später
zum Verhängnis werden.
Attention à lui!
Hinter Jane Birkin zu sitzen -
ein grosser Moment?
Es war sehr angenehm.
Kennen Sie ihren Song
"Je t'aime ... moi non plus"?
Der wurde im Radio verboten, weil er
zu sexuell war.- Ja, den kenne ich.
Sie verkaufte dieses Lied gut.
Ich werde versuchen, den Fussball
auch so gut zu verkaufen,
dass die Leute nicht stöhnen,
sondern Freude haben und klatschen.
Schönen Abend.
Monsieur Josef Blatter: 111.
* Applaus *
Der FIFA-Kongress wählt Aussenseiter
Blatter zum neuen Präsidenten.
Ich bin überwältigt,
wirklich überwältigt.
Und schon taucht der erste Schatten
der Korruption auf:
Von Kuverts voller Geld ist die Rede,
von gekauften afrikanischen Stimmen.
Die SRG konfrontiert ihn damals
mit den Gerüchten:
Was war in den Kuverts, die Sie
im Vorfeld verteilten, Herr Blatter?
Das ist alles ein grosser Mist.
Corinne, wir nehmen den anderen ...
Warum ein grosser Mist?
Weshalb wurden Sie so zitiert?
In der Bar: afrikanische Delegierte.
Der Blatter-Vertraute bin Hammam aus
Katar hätte alles bezahlt, sagen sie.
Wer bezahlte Ihre Flüge?
Transport, Flüge, Hotel -
alles bezahlt
von Herrn bin Hammam aus Katar.
Es war fantastisch,
wir assen Krokodilfleisch.
Er gab uns die Kraft,
für Herrn Blatter zu kämpfen.
Hat man Ihnen etwas versprochen
für Ihre Blatter-Stimme?
Ja.
- Und was?
Er versprach uns Geld.
Alles ohne Folgen für Blatter
und seinen Vertrauten bin Hammam
aus Katar.
Geschickt baut Blatter
ein globales Netzwerk auf -
mit Michel Platini an seiner Seite.
I will introduce you
to His Highness.
Michel Platini de France.
I like that, and I like that.
* Lachen *
Michel, ihn hatte ich wirklich
ins Herz geschlossen.
Die beiden entdecken
das grosse Geschäft im Fussball.
Die grosse Entwicklung erfolgte
erst, nachdem ich Präsident wurde.
Der Weltcup in Frankreich 1998,
bei dem Michel Platini
Organisations-Co-Chef war.
Er sagte immer:
"Nous étions les derniers pauvres"
- "Wir waren die letzten Armen."
Die FIFA - gegründet 1904.
Als Präsident der FIFA
gehört man zum Club
der mächtigsten Männer der Welt.
Zur FIFA gehören 211 Länder.
Die FIFA sagt übrigens gerne,
dass sie mehr Mitglieder habe
als die UNO.
Und alle vier Jahre
organisiert sie die Fussball-WM.
Den WM-Austragungsort
bestimmt damals das Exekutivkomitee,
bestehend aus 24 Männern.
Sepp Blatter ist der Präsident.
Im Exekutivkomitee sitzen u.a.
die Delegierten Julio Grondona ...
... Nicolás Leoz ...
... Ricardo Teixeira ...
... und Michel Platini.
Ihnen werden wir
immer und immer wieder begegnen.
Sie profitieren
vom neuen Geschäftsmodell,
entwickelt von Sepp Blatter
und Michel Platini.
Als dieser Oberwalliser
zur FIFA kommt,
ist es noch
eine kleine Organisation.
Man spricht noch nicht
von Milliarden von Franken.
Doch Sepp Blatter
besitzt den richtigen Geschäftssinn:
Er erhöht die Gebühren
für die TV-Rechte
und gleichzeitig können die Sender
mehr für ihre Werbung kassieren.
Und so gewinnen alle.
Die FIFA wird
zu einer richtigen Geldmaschine.
Doch hinter dem Milliardengeschäft
versteckt sich ein Korruptionssystem.
Blatter hat damals
die Marketingfirma ISL Zug
mit dem Verkauf von TV-Rechten
beauftragt.
(Hansjürg Zumstein)
ISL in Zug ...
TV-Rechte, Bild, Welt.
Doch dann verspekuliert sich
die Zuger Firma ISL und geht Konkurs,
im Jahr 2001.
Die Zuger Justiz
beginnt zu ermitteln.
Es gibt eine Hausdurchsuchung
bei der FIFA und haufenweise Akten.
Das sind ungefähr 2'300 Schachteln,
die wir im Ganzen haben.
Hier in diesem Raum
ist ungefähr ein Drittel der Akten.
Blatter versucht,
die Ermittlungen zu stoppen.
Alles, was im Fussball passiert,
alle Schwierigkeiten im Fussball,
sollen innerhalb
der fussballerischen Gerichtsbarkeit
oder Rechtsprechung gemacht werden
und nicht vor ordentliche Gerichte
gebracht werden.
Das ist nicht mehr unsere Familie.
Unsere Unterlagen zeigen:
Die Zuger Justiz ermittelt dennoch
hartnäckig weiter - jahrelang.
Gerüchte dringen nach draussen.
Ein Journalist
konfrontiert damals Blatter damit.
Eine Million war wohl mal auf dem
FIFA-Konto, ging dann aber weiter.
Das weiss ich nicht.
An Herrn Havelange?
- Das weiss ich nicht.
Die ISL-Schmiergeld-Gerüchte
holen Blatter immer wieder ein.
Ich habe noch nie versucht,
jemanden zu bestechen,
und ich bin nicht bestechlich.
Schauen Sie mir in die Augen.
Was meinen Sie, wie ich dastehe,
mit meinen 1'300 Diensttagen.
Sie wissen nicht,
was ein Schweizer Offizier
im Range eines Regimentskommandanten
als Verantwortung trägt,
und ich komme dann raus
als ein Betrüger.
Nein, so nicht.
Ich nicht.
Der britische Journalist
Andrew Jennings fragt kritisch nach:
Können Sie bestätigen
oder dementieren, dass diese Zahlung
für Herrn Havelange war?
Und wenn nicht, für wen?
Ich diskutiere dies nicht hier
an dieser Pressekonferenz.
Immer wieder streitet Blatter ab.
Dann, nach neun Jahren Ermittlungen,
im Mai 2010,
erlässt die Zuger Justiz
ihre Verfügung.
Jetzt ist erstmals juristisch belegt:
Insgesamt flossen 122 Mio.
an Provisionen, also Schmiergelder,
an verschiedene Funktionäre
von der ISL.
Also eine wahnsinnige Summe.
Zwei bekannte Gesichter
tauchen wieder auf:
Der eine ist Leoz ...
... und der andere ist Teixeira.
Im Exekutivkomitee,
im WM-Wahlgremium,
sitzen also mind. zwei Personen,
die ISL-Schmiergelder
akzeptiert haben.
Und die beiden werden
in wenigen Monaten mitentscheiden,
wer die WM 2022 austragen soll.
Inzwischen ist der ISL-Skandal
weltweit bekannt.
Kurz vor dem Wahltermin
konfrontiert der BBC-Journalist
Jennings die beiden.
(Wir fragten ihn schriftlich,
uns die Zahlungen zu erklären.)
(Keine Antwort.)
(Also versuchte ich, ihn
im Zürcher Luxushotel zu fragen.)
Herr Leoz, haben Sie
Schmiergelder von der ISL kassiert?
(Auch Herr Teixeira
antwortete nicht.)
Please, out!
- Okay.
Herr Teixeira,
können wir miteinander sprechen?
(So I went back to FIFA's hotel
in Zurich to ask him.)
Haben Sie Schmiergelder erhalten?
Wofür waren diese ISL-Zahlungen?
Mr Teixeira?
Oh dear.
Sepp Blatter wusste damals,
dass zwei Mitglieder
des Exekutivkomitees korrupt waren.
Er hätte sie ausschliessen müssen,
tat es aber nicht.
Und wie sieht er das heute?
Warum haben Sie die beiden
zur Abstimmung im Exekutivkomitee
zugelassen?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Sie waren in dem Moment
nicht rechtlich verurteilt,
sonst wären sie
nicht mehr dabei gewesen.
Doch die ISL-Schmiergeldzahlungen
waren öffentlich bekannt.
Eigentlich hätte er handeln müssen.
So sieht das auch
Hans-Joachim Eckert,
später Mitglied
der FIFA-Ethikkommission.
Sie soll Korruption
bei der FIFA verhindern.
Ich war fünf Jahre lang Vorsitzender
der rechtsprechenden Kammer
bei der FIFA.
Das hängt sicherlich
mit meinem beruflichen Werdegang
in der Justiz zusammen -
30 Jahre im Bereich der Bekämpfung
der Wirtschaftskriminalität
und der organisierten Kriminalität.
Eckert sagt,
aufgrund der damaligen Beweislage
wäre der Ausschluss von Leoz
und Teixeira angebracht gewesen.
Wenn man das im Nachhinein so liest,
dann hätte die FIFA
sicherlich reagieren müssen.
Ob das jetzt
Herr Blatter gewesen wäre,
die Rechtsabteilung
oder die Ethikkommission -
es wäre Sache der FIFA gewesen,
darauf zu reagieren,
und das hat sie nicht getan.
Zürich, November 2010,
eine Woche vor der WM-Wahl.
Im FIFA-Exekutivkomitee
sitzt auch Michel Platini,
damals Präsident
des mächtigen Fussballverbands UEFA.
Neun Jahre nach der Katar-Wahl
gibt er im Westschweizer Fernsehen
freimütig Auskunft darüber,
was damals passiert ist.
Bon, allez.
Dieses berühmte Mittagessen vom
23. November 2010 im Élysée-Palast
mit Präsident Sarkozy.
Da war der Kronprinz von Katar,
der mittlerweile Emir geworden ist.
Waren Sie da ein wenig überrascht?
Sie kommen an und ...
Ja, weil ich darum gebeten hatte,
Präsident Sarkozy zu sehen,
um ihm zu sagen,
für wen ich stimmen werde.
Man sagte mir:
"Wir organisieren ein Mittagessen."
Ich war einverstanden.
Als ich dort ankam, sass
auch der Emir von Katar am Tisch.
Aber sie haben mich nie gebeten,
für Katar zu stimmen,
sie haben nichts von mir verlangt.
Nur als ich rausging,
rief ich Blatter an und sagte:
"Ich glaube, ich bin da
an einen Ort gelangt ...".
Bis eine Woche vor dem Entscheid
war alles picobello.
Aber dann rief mich
Michel Platini an
und erzählte mir von dem Mittagessen
mit dem Staatspräsidenten.
Das war Sarkozy damals.
Der Staatspräsident hätte gefragt,
ob er mit seinen Stimmberechtigten
mithelfen könnte,
den Weltcup nach Katar zu bringen.
Ich fragte ihn, ob er denn gesagt
hätte, er müsse für sie stimmen.
Platini sagte: "Nein."
Aber wenn dich der Staatspräsident
um etwas bittet,
ob du etwas machen könntest ...
Er sagte, wir müssten
auf jeden Fall aufpassen.
Er habe seine Leute,
die abstimmen -
er und drei andere,
das sind insgesamt vier Stimmen.
War das eine Art Falle?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Vielleicht
wollte Präsident Sarkozy zeigen,
dass Frankreich
Katar unterstützt bei der WM-Wahl.
Aber er hat mich nie gebeten,
für Katar zu stimmen.
Eine subtile Form von Druck:
Sie kommen zum Mittagessen
und treffen ihn dort an.
Nein, ich kenne die Katarer
seit 30 Jahren.
So funktioniert das.
Sie präsentierten einen Monat vorher
ihr Projekt in der FIFA.
Ich habe es nicht nötig,
dass Präsident Sarkozy
sie mit mir zusammenbringt.
Wir realisieren also:
Es gibt politische Einflussnahme
auf höchster Ebene.
Fünf Nationen
bewerben sich für die WM 2022:
Katar, USA, Südkorea,
Australien und Japan.
Favorit sind die USA.
I hope that you feel as I do,
that the USA
would make an excellent host.
Am Vorabend der Abstimmung tele-
fonierte ich mit Präsident Obama.
Er fragte, wie es laufen würde,
und ich sagte,
ich hätte keine guten Nachrichten.
Ich würde nicht wissen,
wie es herauskäme,
sicher sei nichts,
aber es sähe nicht sehr gut aus.
Zürich, 2. Dezember 2010.
Der Tag der WM-Wahl.
Das Exekutivkomitee
trifft sich im FIFA-Hauptgebäude
hinter verschlossenen Türen,
im sog. Boardroom,
drei Stockwerke tief unter der Erde.
Blatter weiss: Platini und seine drei
Verbündeten werden für Katar stimmen.
Und:
Teixeira und Leoz
haben ISL-Schmiergelder kassiert.
* Triumphale Musik *
The winner to organise
the 2022 FIFA World Cup ...
... is Qatar.
* Jubel *
(Beni Thurnheer) Katar,
das ist eine Riesenüberraschung.
Das ist jetzt ein Knaller.
Offenbar hat man bei der FIFA
also das Gefühl,
dass die Ölquellen
dort weiter sprudeln werden,
auch in zwölf Jahren.
Ich kann es fast nicht fassen:
Das kleine Katar hat die Grossen,
USA und Australien,
in die Schranken gewiesen.
Wir lassen Sie nicht im Stich.
Sie werden stolz auf uns
und auf den Mittleren Osten sein,
das verspreche ich.
* Applaus *
War es ein Fehler?
Der ganze Ärger für Sie und Blatter
und für viele andere
begann mit der Wahl von Katar.
Nein. Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Sie werden sehen,
es wird die schönste WM sein.
Wir stellten also fest,
dass es politische Einflussnahme
auf die Nomination Katars gab.
Aber es gab noch mehr.
Wir sehen in den
amerikanischen Akten, dass die USA
kurz nach der Katar-Wahl
mit den Ermittlungen begannen.
Und wir stossen in den Akten
auf zwei bekannte Namen:
Teixeira und Leoz,
die beiden ISL-Schmiergelder-Bezüger.
Auch bei den US-Ermittlungen
geht es um Schmiergelder.
Die amerikanische Justiz hat -
aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
da gibt es natürlich Vermutungen,
man hätte gerne die WM bekommen ...
Jedenfalls machten die Amerikaner
das, was sie gut können:
Sie nahmen auch
die Spur des Geldes auf.
Trotz des Schattens der Korruption:
Blatters Präsidentenkarriere
nimmt vorerst keinen Schaden.
Number of votes
for Mr Josef S. Blatter: 139.
Er wird dreimal wiedergewählt.
* Applaus *
We are all good.
Yes, do it! Do it!
Do it!
It's for the unity of football.
It's for football.
Okay. Thank you.
Herzlich willkommen, Herr Blatter.
- Make the world a better place.
Ich sage nur: "Boa noite!"
- Boa noite.
Monsieur Teixeira,
c'est la Coupe du monde de la FIFA.
Der Pokal aus brasilianischen
Händen.- Danke schön.
Nun sitzt der König der Fussballwelt
also wieder auf seinem Thron.
186.
Presidente Josef Blatter.
The FIFA World Cup
is in South Africa.
A dream came true.
Zürich, Mai 2015.
Vorbereitungen
für den 65. FIFA-Kongress.
Die vierte Wiederwahl
von Sepp Blatter steht an.
Die über 200 Funktionäre logieren
in den besten Hotels von Zürich.
Zeitlich stehen wir
fünf Jahre nach der Katar-Wahl,
fünf Jahre
nach der Niederlage der USA.
Im Luxushotel Baur au Lac
geniessen die höchsten
FIFA-Offiziellen die Bedienung.
Dann überstürzen sich
die Nachrichten:
(Kommentatorin)
Arrestations à la FIFA.
Plusieurs responsables interpellés
ce matin par la police Suisse
révèle à l'instant
le "New York Times".
First, our top story today:
The football world's top body
is in crisis again.
We are expecting
to hear from the FBI later.
Wir sind entschlossen,
diese Praktiken zu beenden,
die Korruption auszutrocknen und die
Fehlbaren vor Gericht zu bringen.
(Kommentatorin) Die Kantons-
polizisten agieren in Zivil,
denn im Hotel logieren
auch zahlreiche Journalisten.
Diese fotografieren
und berichten später
vom äusserst diskreten Vorgehen.
Ich erfuhr es aus dem Radio.
Ich dachte,
das sei ein schlechter Film,
das sei nicht wahr,
das könne nicht wahr sein.
Die Polizei
verhaftet zehn hohe FIFA-Offizielle.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Leoz und Teixeira
sind nicht im Baur au Lac.
Sie sind gar nicht angereist.
Jetzt werden sie international
zur Verhaftung ausgeschrieben.
Sie hätten garantieren sollen, dass
Fussball ehrlich und sauber ist.
Stattdessen
korrumpierten sie den Fussball,
schauten auf ihr Eigeninteresse
und bereicherten sich.
Sie taten es immer und immer wieder,
Jahr für Jahr, Turnier um Turnier.
Ladies and Gentlemen, today ...
Der FIFA-Präsident
tanzt heute nicht in seinem Büro.
Er ist, na ja ... ruhig
und verfolgt das Geschehen.
Die FIFA begrüsst diesen Prozess
und kooperiert voll
mit der Bundesanwaltschaft
und dann entsprechend auch
mit dem Bundesamt für Justiz.
Auftritt von Michael Lauber,
Schweizer Bundesanwalt,
Seite an Seite mit der
US-Justizministerin Loretta Lynch.
Noch ahnt niemand, dass bald daraus
eine Schweizer Justizaffäre wird.
Das öffentliche Interesse an den
Schweizer Ermittlungen ist enorm.
Deshalb haben wir entschieden,
Sie über den Stand
unserer Ermittlungen zu informieren.
Ich kann bestätigen,
dass die Bundesanwaltschaft
zusammen mit Justizministerin Lynch
kontinuierlich den Umfang der
strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen prüft.
Es ist mir eine grosse Ehre,
nun das Wort an
meine amerikanischen Amtskollegin,
Generalstaatsanwältin Loretta Lynch,
zu übergeben.
Danke, Michael.
Das Problem der Fussballkorruption
ist global.
Wir wollen mit unseren Bemühungen
eine globale Antwort finden.
Dieser Mann wird alles verändern:
der Argentinier Alejandro Burzaco.
Er reist ahnungslos nach Zürich,
und auch er
steht auf der US-Fahndungsliste.
Maria Roselli
hat seine Geschichte recherchiert.
Am Tag der aufsehenerregenden
Verhaftungen im Baur au Lac
kam Alejandro Burzaco
zu spät zum Frühstück.
Als die anderen verhaftet wurden,
war er also nicht dort.
Er nutzt sofort die Gelegenheit
und flüchtete nach Italien -
er ist auch
italienischer Staatsbürger.
In Italien bleibt er zwei Tage lang,
ohne genau zu wissen,
wie er sich verhalten soll.
Danach tauscht er sich mit
seinem Anwalt aus und beschliesst,
sich der US-Justiz zu stellen.
Die amerikanischen Ermittler
holen ihn ab
und bringen ihn
direkt nach New York.
Dort beginnt er,
mit der US-Justiz zu kooperieren
und erzählt alles, was er weiss.
Er übergibt der US-Justiz
sein BlackBerry.
Darauf befinden sich Tausende
von E-Mails und Korrespondenzen
mit vielen Fussballfunktionären.
Ein Geschenk des Himmels
für die amerikanischen Behörden.
So können sie
ihre Ermittlungen fortsetzen.
Eigentlich sind die FIFA-Offiziellen
nach Zürich angereist,
um den Präsidenten zu wählen.
Trotz Baur au Lac: Der 79-Jährige
hält an der Kandidatur fest.
Militärisch gesprochen
war es ein Angriff auf die FIFA,
also muss der Kommandant
an Bord bleiben.
Er darf nicht fliehen.
Das ist meine militärische
Erziehung: Ich als Chef bleibe hier.
Doch Blatter gerät
von unerwarteter Seite unter Druck:
Sein Vertrauter
und Freund Michel Platini lanciert
zusammen mit UEFA-Generalsekretär
Gianni Infantino den Angriff.
Wir haben - wie Sie alle - verfolgt,
was in den letzten Tagen
passiert ist.
Und ehrlich gesagt:
Ich, der die FIFA liebt,
ich, ein grosser Bewunderer
der FIFA-Geschichte,
ich, der das seit Jahren verfolgt,
ich bin empört, angewidert,
ich habe es satt.
Genug ist genug.
Enough is enough.
Donc, c'est trop. Trop, c'est trop.
Platini kam zu mir nach Hause
und sagte zu mir:
"Kandidiere nicht."
Ich antwortete: "Wie meinst du das?"
"Ich bin der Präsident,
und die Wahlen sind traktandiert."
"Ich werde den Kongress durchführen
und mich der Wiederwahl stellen."
Ich antwortete ihm:
"Schade, es wäre gut für dein Image,
wenn du die Lage begreifst
und uns verlässt."
Ich kann Ihnen garantieren:
An der morgigen Wahl wird eine
Mehrheit der europäischen Verbände
für den Prinzen Ali stimmen.
Noch ahnt Platini nicht, dass sein
Generalsekretär Gianni Infantino
neun Monate später auf dem
FIFA-Präsidentenstuhl sitzen wird.
In den nächsten Monaten
folgt ein erbitterter Machtkampf
zwischen den drei Alphatieren.
Zunächst aber, am 29. Mai 2015,
zwei Tage nach den Verhaftungen
im Baur au Lac:
Sepp Blatter
unterwegs zur Wiederwahl.
Als wäre nichts geschehen.
Ganz einfach:
Ich möchte bei euch bleiben,
mit euch weiter zusammenarbeiten.
Man darf nicht vergessen:
Das war ein Angriff auf die FIFA -
das verletzt, das verletzt.
Le Président de la FIFA élu.
Je vous prie de bien vouloir
acclamer très fort
pour cette élection.
* Applaus *
Doch der mediale Druck ist gewaltig.
Zürich, 2. Juni 2015,
vier Tage nach der Wiederwahl.
Mein Mandat
hat nicht die Unterstützung
der gesamten Fussballwelt.
Deshalb stelle ich es
anlässlich eines ausserordentlichen
Wahlkongresses zur Verfügung.
Ich danke Ihnen
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich habe auf Druck reagiert,
auch von der amerikanischen Justiz.
Sie hatte vor,
die FIFA zu einer
mafiösen Gesellschaft zu erklären,
womöglich mit dem Nebengedanken,
an das viele Geld zu kommen.
Seine letzte FIFA-Pressekonferenz
endet mit einem Eklat.
... 2026.
- Excuse me.
Sorry, this is ...
We are starting a press conference.
Security, come on!
Come on!
Here we go, Sepp!
Ladies and Gentlemen.
Wir müssen hier zuerst aufräumen.
Das hat nichts mit Fussball zu tun.
Ich bin gleich zurück.
Nach Baur au Lac
und zwei Monate nach Blatters Abgang:
(Katja Stauber) Michel Platini
wirft den Hut in den Ring
und will die Führung der FIFA
übernehmen.
Der heutige UEFA-Funktionär
will damit Nachfolger
von Sepp Blatter werden.
Platini ist sehr gut gestartet.
Er hat bereits die Unterstützung
von vier Kontinentalverbänden:
Europa,
Süd- und Nordamerika und Karibik.
Platini ist also als Favorit
praktisch gewählt.
Zwei Monate später:
Die Journalisten warten auf
Neuigkeiten aus dem Exekutivkomitee.
Eine Routine-Pressekonferenz.
(Rainer Maria Salzgeber)
Die FIFA hatte heute um 14 Uhr
eine Pressekonferenz angesetzt.
Sie wurde zuerst
um eine Stunde verschoben,
bevor sie kurz vor 15 Uhr
definitiv abgesagt wurde.
Im Nachhinein wurde schnell klar,
weshalb.
Die Ermittlungen
gegen den Weltfussballverband FIFA
wegen Korruption werden ausgeweitet.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft führte heute
mit Unterstützung
der Bundeskriminalpolizei
eine Hausdurchsuchung beim
FIFA-Hauptquartier in Zürich durch.
Zudem wurde Herr Josef Blatter
als Beschuldigter einvernommen
und Monsieur Michel Platini
als Auskunftsperson befragt.
Sie holen uns in ein Büro
während einer Sitzung
des FIFA-Exekutivkomitees.
Unten warten 200 Journalisten.
Warum dieses Theater?
Für zwei in der Schweiz
wohnhafte Personen?
Es ging darum, uns zu schaden.
Sie führten mich und Platini
nach der Sitzung ab.
Dann fragte mich Michel noch:
"Tu sais pourquoi?"
Ich antwortete: "Pas du tout."
Danach trennten sie uns.
Sie zeigten mir
den Brief von Platini und ...
Der Brief:
Platini verlangt im Jahr 2011
nachträglich 2 Mio. Fr. Honorar
für eine Beratung,
die über acht Jahre zurückliegt.
Über diesen Brief
werden beide stürzen.
Platini und ich
hatten einen Vertrag,
einen mündlichen Vertrag.
Er verdiente damals eine Million
im Jahr - das hatte er mir gesagt.
So haben sie laut Platini verhandelt:
Wie viel willst du?
- 1 Mio.
Von was?- Rubel,
französische Franken, Dollar ...
Einverstanden, 1 Mio. Fr. pro Jahr.
Als ich gewählt wurde,
habe ich ihn engagiert
als meinen Mitarbeiter
für technische Aufträge.
Wir hatten aber keine Million,
um ihn zu bezahlen.
Hast du ein Problem zu zahlen?
- Ja, ich kann keine Million zahlen.
Der Generalsekretär
verdient 300'000,
ich kann dir nicht
dreimal mehr zahlen.
Wir werden dir einen Vertrag
für 300'000 machen
und den Rest später zahlen.
Wir haben den Vertrag vergessen -
ich habe nicht mehr daran gedacht.
Und eines Tages ...
... schrieb er der FIFA einen Brief
und sagte,
er wolle den Rest
von seinem Lohn haben.
Am Ende sagten wir:
"Gut, wir zahlen dir 2 Mio."
FIFA-Ethikkommission.
(Maria Roselli)
Commissione etica.
Die FIFA-Ethikkommission
ist ein internes Kontrollgremium.
Ihre Aufgabe ist, zu prüfen,
ob diese Funktionäre
den Ethikcode einhalten -
also ob es Korruption gibt
oder nicht.
Dafür war damals
Hans-Joachim Eckert zuständig,
als vorsitzender Richter
der Ethikkommission.
Er fällt ein Urteil, das
in der FIFA-Geschichte einmalig ist.
President Blatter
has been suspended for 90 days.
* Er spricht russisch. *
FIFA-Präsident Blatter
muss seinen Stuhl räumen.
FIFA suspends President Sepp Blatter
and Vice-President Michel Platini.
Ich habe damals nicht allein
entschieden für die Ethikkommission
der rechtsprechenden Kammer.
Ich habe mit drei anderen Beisitzern
gemeinsam geprüft,
ob wir das Verfahren eröffnen
oder nicht.
Und Sie können mir glauben:
Das macht man sich nicht leicht,
gegen die zwei vorsitzenden
Präsidenten der UEFA und der FIFA
offiziell ein Verfahren zu eröffnen,
mit der gleichzeitigen Massnahme,
dass sie vorläufig gesperrt sind.
Aus der vorläufigen Sperre wird
zwei Monate später eine definitive.
Es tut mir leid für den Fussball,
aber es tut mir auch leid wegen mir,
wie ich behandelt werde
in dieser Welt der Menschlichkeit.
Es ist vielleicht
ganz gut zu wissen:
So etwas
bricht man nicht übers Knie,
sondern man macht sich
darüber Gedanken.
Man sperrt nicht so ohne Weiteres
den mächtigsten Fussballmann
der Welt.
Da will man keinen Fehler machen.
Können Sie nachvollziehen,
dass diese Methoden
ein bisschen mafiös erscheinen?
1 Mio. pro Jahr.
Ja? Nein? Ein bisschen mehr?
Ich denke nicht. Ich denke,
es ist ein Gentlemen's Agreement.
Morgen werden die Journalisten
schreiben: "Blatter ist am Ende."
Blatter ist nicht am Ende,
solange er lebt.
Sie tragen dieses Pflaster.
Sie liessen sich ein
evtl. bösartiges Melanom entfernen.
Sie sind 79-jährig.
Man sollte auch loslassen können.
Ich kann die FIFA loslassen,
aber nicht mich selbst.
Ich bin Schweizer Bürger.
Ich will für meine Rechte
und für die Gerechtigkeit kämpfen.
Nach der Sperre: aus der Traum
als FIFA-Präsidentschaftskandidat.
Ich sage die Wahrheit,
die ganze Wahrheit,
nur die Wahrheit.
Ich schwöre es.
Es war sehr schwierig.
Ich verstand es nicht.
Ich begriff nicht,
wie das passieren konnte.
Ich wurde als Bilanzfälscher, als
korrupt, als Geldwäscher bezeichnet.
Überall, in allen Medien.
Ich habe 20 Jahre lang
für die FIFA gearbeitet,
die Weltmeisterschaft
ehrenamtlich organisiert.
Es ist die FIFA,
die mir Geld überweist,
und es ist die gleiche FIFA,
die mich suspendiert,
weil sie mir Geld überwiesen hat.
Ich versuche, zu verstehen,
aber es fällt mir schwer.
Und das ist immer noch so?
- Ja, das ist immer noch so.
Die beiden kämpfen bis heute
um ihre Ehre.
Mussten Blatter und Platini gehen,
damit er an die Macht kommt?
Gianni Infantino,
Platinis UEFA-Generalsekretär.
Über diese Frage
wird bis heute gestritten.
Unser Datenvergleich zeigt aber:
Jetzt geht es Schlag auf Schlag.
Baur-au-Lac-Verhaftungen,
Demission Blatter,
Kandidatur Platini,
2-Millionen-Vorwurf,
provisorische
und schliesslich definitive Sperre
von Blatter und Platini.
Und nur 20 Tage
nach der provisorischen Sperre
kandidiert bereits
der kaum bekannte Gianni Infantino.
FIFA-Wahlkongress,
26. Februar 2016 in Zürich.
Ich möchte heute zu Ihnen
aus vollem Herzen sprechen.
Vor fünf Monaten
hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass ich heute
vor Ihnen stehen würde,
dass ich Kandidat sein würde
für das FIFA-Präsidentenamt.
Aber in den letzten Monaten
ist viel passiert.
Die FIFA
befindet sich in einer Krise,
in einer schwierigen Situation.
Ihr Ruf ist angeschlagen,
man spricht von Korruption,
Gerichten, Anwälte, was auch immer.
Infantino
war ein bisschen der ewige Zweite
an der Seite von Platini
bei der UEFA.
Er stand ab und zu im Rampenlicht -
z.B. bei den Auslosungen
der Mannschaften
für die Europameisterschaften.
Dann verschwand er wieder.
Aber als 2015
all diese Verwicklungen und Intrigen
bei der FIFA auftauchten,
da nimmt er seine Chance wahr.
Und wenn die Situation
schwierig ist, liebe Freunde,
gibt es zwei Optionen:
Entweder man versteckt sich
oder man stellt sich.
Für mich war Verstecken nie eine
Option, ich wollte immer handeln
und tun, was richtig ist.
(Mann) Le nombre total des votes
valables recueillis par Gianni: 115.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Seine Entourage und seine Frau
feiern.
Er ist der richtige Mann,
er wird es elegant lösen.
Viva Gianni!
Bravo!
* Applaus *
Wir lesen in den Unterlagen immer
wieder von einer Komplott-Theorie:
Infantino habe bei der Blatter-
Platini-Sperre eine Rolle gespielt.
Infantino dementiert energisch.
Sepp Blatter
hat eine klare Meinung dazu:
Auf jeden Fall
sollte Platini nicht anwesend sein.
Er war sein Gegner Nummer 1.
Wenn Platini da gewesen wäre,
wäre er nie gewählt geworden.
Platini wäre Präsident.
Es war bösartig,
schlau und bösartig.
Ein perfides Spiel.
War er Ihrer Meinung nach aktiv?
Ja, er war intelligent und aktiv.
- Und wie?
Ich denke, er hat es gewusst.
Ich denke, Infantino
wollte zuerst UEFA-Präsident werden,
und dann hat er realisiert,
dass der FIFA-Stuhl frei wird.
Und dann ... Ich weiss nicht,
das muss man die Ermittler fragen.
Die Wahrheit
wird ans Tageslicht kommen.
Ich kenne sie nicht ganz,
aber ich orientiere mich an denen,
die sich dazu äussern wollen.
* Applaus *
Guten Abend.
Willkommen, Gianni Infantino.
Danke, dass Sie einen Zwischenstopp
bei uns einlegen.
Sie sind ja Weltreisender.
Sie kommen gerade aus Doha
und gehen dann
gleich weiter nach London.
Schon wieder ein Walliser.
Wie sind die Reaktionen?
Wir Walliser
kommen gut bei den Leuten an.
Walliserdeutsch verstehen die Leute
inzwischen weltweit relativ gut.
Es ist die Sprache Nummer 1
bei der FIFA. Das kommt gut an.
Aufgewachsen ist Infantino in Brig,
mit zwei älteren Schwestern.
Er war ein kleiner Piccolino -
ein kleiner Verwöhnter,
aber ein liebenswerter.
Seine Eltern kommen als italienische
Gastarbeiter in den 60er-Jahren
nach Brig - der Vater Hilfsarbeiter,
die Mutter Kioskverkäuferin.
Der kleine Gianni
liest italienische Gazetten
und träumt
von einer Fussballkarriere.
Er spielt beim FC Brig-Glis.
Jugendfreund Rinaldo Arnold
ist dort Präsident.
Er kam im Oktober vorbei.
Die zweite Mannschaft
hatte gerade ein Spiel.
Er meinte, er komme gerne zuschauen.
Keine Starallüren, nichts.
Er ist immer noch einer
vom FC Brig-Glis,
sympathisch und umgänglich.
Infantino verspricht eine neue FIFA.
Reformen sind absolut notwendig,
das ist das A und O -
Transparenz, Good Governance usw.
Jetzt müssen wir zeigen, dass wir so
in Zukunft arbeiten werden -
ab jetzt, ab heute, eine neue Ära.
Sein erster Arbeitstag nach der Wahl.
Er beginnt mit einem Fussballspiel.
Auf den ersten Blick harmlos.
Alles bekannte Stars.
Alles Freunde.
Ich habe versprochen,
dass an meinem ersten Tag bei
der FIFA der Fussball zurück ist.
Ein paar Anrufe, alle sind da.
Harmlos bis auf einen,
bis auf diesen unscheinbaren Mann:
Rinaldo Arnold, kein Fussballstar,
sondern der Jugendfreund aus Brig.
Er ist v.a. ein nützlicher Freund:
Er ist Walliser Oberstaatsanwalt -
und er kennt André Marty,
den Informationschef
der Bundesanwaltschaft.
Marty kommt auch aus dem Wallis.
Sein Vorgesetzter heisst
Michael Lauber, der Bundesanwalt.
Lauber leitet die Korruptions-
verfahren rund um die FIFA und UEFA.
SRF-Redaktor Oliver Washington hat
Michael Laubers Karriere verfolgt.
Quasi über Nacht
habe sich alles verändert -
durch die Enthüllungen der sog.
Football Leaks und der Panama Papers.
Tausende von vertraulichen Mails.
Das sind Dokumente,
die Journalisten zugespielt wurden.
Das war ein Riesenthema,
bei dem es um viele Fragen ging.
In der Schweiz hat der "Tages-
Anzeiger" die Dokumente ausgewertet.
Das brisante Ergebnis:
Sozusagen als Zufallstreffer,
als Zufallsfund über Mails und SMS
fand man heraus,
dass sich Lauber heimlich
mit der FIFA-Spitze getroffen hatte.
Die berühmten Geheimtreffen.
Wir vergleichen die Daten mit den uns
bereits bekannten Ereignissen.
Und wir staunen:
das erste Treffen am 8. Juli 2015.
Heikel:
noch vor der Sperre Blatter-Platini,
noch vor der Wahl Infantinos.
Ging es hier
um Infantinos eventuelle Kandidatur?
Bei diesem ersten Treffen
waren Herr Lauber,
sein Mediensprecher
und Rinaldo Arnold dabei.
Rinaldo Arnold
begründete später dieses Treffen so,
dass er sich über die Arbeitsweise
der Bundesanwaltschaft
hätte informieren wollen.
Das überrascht,
weil ein Walliser Oberstaatsanwalt
die Schweizer Justiz so gut
kennen sollte, dass er auch weiss,
wie die Bundesanwaltschaft
funktioniert.
Zwei Wochen nach Infantinos Wahl
geht es weiter.
Arnold schreibt am 5. März 2016:
Bundesanwalt Lauber trifft heimlich
den FIFA-Präsidenten Infantino,
obwohl die Bundesanwaltschaft
eigentlich wegen Korruptionsvorwürfen
rund um die FIFA-Wahl von Katar 22
ermittelt.
Das Treffen
findet am 22. März statt -
nicht etwa in der Bundesanwaltschaft,
nein,
im Hotel Schweizerhof in Bern.
Ein Hotel im Besitz
eines katarischen Staatsfonds.
Und: Im Schweizerhof befindet sich
auch die Botschaft von Katar.
Geheimtreffen mit der FIFA-Spitze
in einem Katar-Hotel
und gleichzeitig Ermittlungen,
ob es bei der Katar-Wahl
zu Korruption kam -
eine heikle Kombination.
6 avril 2016.
Kurz danach,
zwei Wochen nach dem Geheimtreffen:
Laubers Bundesanwaltschaft führt eine
Hausdurchsuchung bei der UEFA durch,
bei Infantinos
ehemaligem Arbeitgeber.
Am UEFA-Hauptsitz in Nyon wurde
heute eine Razzia durchgeführt,
denn in den Panama Papers
taucht auch ein bekannter Name auf:
Gianni Infantino,
der frühere UEFA-Generalsekretär
und jetzige FIFA-Präsident.
Der Hintergrund:
Infantino schloss damals
mit zwei dubiosen TV-Rechtehändlern
Verträge ab.
Die beiden sind in den USA angeklagt.
Ist der neue FIFA-Präsident
in unsaubere Geschäfte verwickelt?
Der Verdacht
wird später noch viel zu reden geben.
Infantino stört,
dass er in den Medien
zusammen mit der UEFA-Razzia
erwähnt wird.
Er schickt seinem Jugendfreund
eine SMS.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft lehnt zwar ab,
aber zehn Tage später trifft sich
Infantino erneut mit Lauber -
jetzt ein Geheimtreffen in Zürich,
im Restaurant Au Premier.
Infantino fliegt dafür eigens mit dem
Privatjet des Emirs von Katar an.
All dies hätte die Öffentlichkeit
nie erfahren sollen.
Im Herbst 2018
werden die Football Leaks bekannt.
Dann folgt die berühmte
Pressekonferenz von Lauber.
Dann tritt er vor die Medien.
Lauber zusammen mit Marty.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Werte Medienschaffende, Tag wohl -
ich darf Sie vielleicht zumindest
auf Walliserdeutsch begrüssen.
Besten Dank für Ihr Interesse an
der Arbeit der Bundesanwaltschaft.
Damit bitte schön, Michael Lauber.
Good morning, guten Morgen.
Am 6. April 2016
wurde ein Strafverfahren im
Zusammenhang mit der UEFA eröffnet.
Am 22. April 2016 kam es zu einem
zweiten und abschliessenden Treffen
zwischen mir und Gianni Infantino
in Zürich.
Und ich habe ja zu keinem Zeitpunkt,
weder in diesen Treffen noch
irgendwie sonst mit Gianni Infantino
oder mit Vertretern der UEFA
über diese Sache gesprochen.
(Journalist) Warum wurden
diese Treffen nicht protokolliert?
Das waren übergeordnete Treffen
zur strategischen Steuerung
der Verfahren.
Deswegen hat
die Dokumentationspflicht der StPO
meiner Ansicht nach nichts zu tun
mit der konkreten
Dokumentationspflicht,
die diese StPO für die konkreten
Verfahrenshandlungen vorsieht.
Sonst müsste ich jedes einzelne
Treffen, mit irgendjemandem,
nur weil es die BA
oder der BA macht,
im weitesten Sinne dokumentieren.
Das würde in eine
total falsche Richtung führen.
Dann bereuen Sie
dieses Treffen nicht,
trotz des dadurch
verursachten Wirbels?
Nein, ich bereue es nicht,
weil ich ...
Ich kann ja nicht
meine Pflicht bereuen.
Ich sehe das wirklich
als meine Pflicht.
Ich mache es auch
in anderen Verfahren.
Es ist wirklich nötig.
Ich sage es Ihnen.
Und wenn das nicht mehr nötig
und meine Pflicht sein darf,
dann habe ich
ein absolutes Grundsatzproblem.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Das Interessante
bei dieser Medienkonferenz war,
dass Lauber so tat,
als sei es das Normalste der Welt,
sich heimlich mit
Verfahrensbeteiligten zu treffen.
Er wollte damit sicher auch
die Bedeutung dieser Treffen
herunterspielen.
Interessant
war auch seine Begründung,
weshalb diese Treffen
nicht protokolliert wurden.
Er sagte - salopp gesagt -,
das wäre zu aufwendig gewesen.
Und noch etwas fällt auf
bei Laubers Auftritt:
Lauber sagte
an dieser Pressekonferenz,
dass es zwischen ihm und Infantino
zwei Treffen gegeben habe
und dass das zweite Treffen das
abschliessende Treffen gewesen sei.
Auch gegenüber der Aufsicht später
sagte er,
es hätte
keine weiteren Treffen gegeben.
Es stellte sich aber heraus, dass es
noch ein weiteres Treffen gab
zwischen Lauber und Infantino -
im Hotel Schweizerhof in Bern.
Das ist insofern fatal,
weil Lauber somit offensichtlich
die Unwahrheit erzählt hat.
Rinaldo Arnold mittlerweile
schon per Du mit André Marty.
Fünf Monate später.
Classement ...
L'affaire UEFA-Infantino -
classement.
Classement - eingestellt.
Laubers Bundesanwaltschaft handelt.
Einige Monate später wird
die UEFA-Untersuchung eingestellt,
was Infantino
in gewisser Weise entlastet.
Es stellt sich natürlich die Frage,
ob sie darüber gesprochen haben,
ob das Treffen
eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Weshalb die Bundesanwaltschaft
das Verfahren einstellte,
darüber wird noch heute,
fünf Jahre später, spekuliert.
Zwei ausserordentliche Staatsanwälte
ermitteln.
Die SRG konfrontiert damals Lauber
mit dem vergessenen Treffen.
Wir sind Ende letzten Jahres
die Agenden manuell durchgegangen
und haben dieses mögliche
dritte Treffen nicht gefunden.
Das ist ein Fehler.
Da ist uns ein Lapsus passiert.
Das kann geschehen, bei meiner
Agenda mit den vielen Terminen.
Muss ich das einfach glauben?
- Ich habe nichts verschwiegen.
Ich lüge nicht.
Es ist die simple Wahrheit,
auch wenn sie vielleicht
eine unangenehme ist.
Lauber sagt,
er könne sich an dieses Treffen
sowie an den Inhalt dieses Treffens
nicht erinnern.
Jedenfalls kommt er wegen
diesem letzten Treffen unter Druck.
Die Aufsicht erachtet Laubers
Ausführungen als nicht glaubwürdig.
Sie leitet dann
eine Disziplinaruntersuchung ein.
Es kommt zu einem Kräftemessen
zwischen Lauber und der Aufsicht.
Lauber erachtet
diese Disziplinaruntersuchung
als Eingriff in die Unabhängigkeit
der Bundesanwaltschaft
sowie als Angriff
gegen ihn als Person.
Auf die Disziplinaruntersuchung
reagiert Michael Lauber
mit einer Pressekonferenz.
Ich lüge nicht
und verschweige auch nichts.
Ich weise diese Vorwürfe
in aller Form zurück.
Die ganze Diskussion auf mein
Erinnerungsvermögen zu reduzieren
und das als Kardinalfehler darzu-
stellen, der meinen Kopf fordert ...
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen:
Das ist einfach nur absurd.
Und Infantino?
Kann er sich noch erinnern, worüber
er mit Lauber gesprochen hat?
Wir sind heute
im FIFA-Museum in Zürich.
Ich kann mich beim besten Willen
nicht mehr genau erinnern.
Aber woran ich mich
mit Sicherheit erinnere:
dass alles korrekt ablief.
Wenn ich Sie frage,
was Sie vor einem Monat
zu Mittag gegessen haben:
Wissen Sie das noch?
- Das vielleicht nicht,
aber an ein Treffen mit dem Bundes-
anwalt würde ich mich erinnern.
Ich habe jeden Monat,
jede Woche x Treffen.
Beim besagten dritten Treffen
war ich am Vortag in Peking
und traf Chinas Präsidenten.
Tags darauf war ich
in St. Petersburg, traf Putin
und hielt anlässlich
der Eröffnung des Confederations Cup
eine Rede vor 65'000 Menschen.
Dass ich mich da
nicht ganz genau erinnern kann ...
Man kann mich tadeln,
ich tadle mich selber auch dafür.
Aber allein die Idee, dass man
zum Bundesanwalt gehen kann,
dem obersten Staatsanwalt
der Schweiz,
um irgendetwas Krummes zu machen ...
Allein schon diese Idee
liegt jenseits der Vorstellungskraft
von irgendjemandem,
der auch nur 0,1 % Hirn
im Kopf hat.
Damals sass Hans-Joachim Eckert
in der Ethikkommission.
Von den Geheimtreffen
wusste er nichts.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man sich
hier privat treffen musste.
Und dass sich keiner mehr an dieses
dritte Treffen in Bern erinnert,
das geht in den Bereich
des Skurrilen.
In diese Situation kommt man
als Richter des Öfteren im Leben.
Die kollektive Amnesie
in manchen Bereichen -
gerade in grossen Wirtschafts-
verfahren oder Bankverfahren -
ist doch sehr tiefgreifend.
Aber warum hat Eckert
nicht gehandelt,
als die Geheimtreffen Ende 2018
aufflogen, fragen wir uns?
Wir realisieren:
Infantino baut - ein Jahr im Amt -
das interne Kontrollgremium,
die Ethikkommission, um.
Es gibt Neuwahlen am 11. Mai 2017.
Wir erinnern uns:
Eckert
hat Blatter und Platini gesperrt
wegen der 2-Millionen-Zahlung.
Der Weltfussballverband brachte sich
im Vorfeld seines Kongresses
in Bahrain ins Gespräch und
ein Stück weit auch ins Zwielicht.
Es gab eine interne Liste.
Darauf waren die Namen von Cornel
Borbély und allen anderen darauf.
Und dann kam also auch
die Einladung nach Bahrain
und auch die Flugtickets
und die Hotelbuchung.
Wir flogen dann hin.
Und als wir ausgestiegen
und die Handys wieder gingen,
durften wir
durch die Medien vernehmen,
dass die Wiederwahl
der Ethikkommission
in der Form nicht mehr anstand.
Hans-Joachim Eckert aus Deutschland
und Corner Borbély aus der Schweiz
müssen ihren Platz räumen.
Beide sind erfahren,
beide sind renommiert.
Ausserhalb der FIFA und im inneren
Zirkel weiss man nicht, warum.
Eckert und Borbély organisieren
vor Ort eine Pressekonferenz.
Wie hat die FIFA
ihre Nichtwiederwahl begründet?
Ich kenne keine Begründung. Wenn Sie
eine haben, bitte ich Sie darum.
Die FIFA hat es nicht begründet?
- Ich habe keine Begründung.
Wir haben dann beide gesagt,
Cornel Borbély und ich,
dass die Ethikkommission
in dieser Form tot ist.
Die wird es so nicht mehr geben.
Am nächsten Tag antwortet Gianni
Infantino auf Journalisten-Fragen so:
Dies ist ein ganz normaler Ablauf.
Der Kongress hat entschieden -
mit über 90 % Stimmen oder so -,
diese neuen Mitglieder zu wählen.
Ich denke, wir sollten daraus
keine Tragödie machen.
(Hansjürg Zumstein)
Hat Herr Infantino Ihnen gegenüber
noch eine Begründung abgegeben
oder mit Ihnen gesprochen? - Nein.
Niemals, es gab keinen Kontakt mehr.
(Hansjürg Zumstein) Eckert
und Borbély waren "scharfe Hunde".
V.a. in den ausländischen Medien
wurde nach ihrer Absetzung
sofort vermutet,
dass Infantino sie durch Leute
ersetzt hat, die ihm "höriger sind".
Man vermutet, dass Infantino
Leute ernennen wollte,
bei denen er sicher war,
dass sie nicht gegen ihn
als Präsidenten vorgehen würden.
Wir studieren
die Akten der US-Justiz.
In dieser Phase von Geheimtreffen,
Gedächtnisschwund
und Absetzung Eckerts
passiert in den USA Brisantes.
(Maria Roselli) Burzaco.
(Hansjürg Zumstein) Kronzeuge.
- Il testimone chiave.
(Ludovic Rocchi) Le témoin clé,
c'est lui.- Questo è lui.
Alles, was wir wissen,
hat er unter Eid ausgesagt.
Er war ein TV-Rechtehändler,
Präsident der Firma Torneos,
für die er viele Jahre arbeitete.
Und er war jahrelang
Teil dieses Bestechungssystems.
Alejandro Burzaco confessou
a lavagem de dinheiro,
fraude e conspiração.
Em Nova Iorque,
o esquema de corrupção na FIFA ...
Alejandro Burzaco
fez novas acusações
contra os dirigentes do futebol ...
Burzaco testemunhou pelo quinto dia
consecutivo em Nova Iorque ...
Die Aussagen von Burzaco fanden in
der Schweiz kaum Echo in den Medien.
In Brasilien hingegen waren die
Enthüllungen aus der Fussballwelt
und auch über Katar
das grosse Thema.
Kronzeuge Burzaco sagt in New York
vor Gericht am 14. November 2017 aus.
Der Wendepunkt.
Wir stehen fünf Jahre
vor dem WM-Start in Katar.
Burzaco
erklärt im Kreuzverhör detailliert,
weshalb die Katar-Wahl
korrupt gewesen sei.
Infantino und seine FIFA
wissen von den brisanten Aussagen.
Hier haben wir
mehr als 850 Seiten Protokoll -
ein grosser Teil davon
seine eidesstattlichen Aussagen.
Sie sind sehr wichtig
für unsere Recherche.
Und auf Seite 402,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
steht es schwarz auf weiss:
"Basierend auf Ihren Gesprächen
mit Julio Grondona,
welche Funktionäre erhielten Geld
für ihre Stimme bei der Katar-Wahl?"
"Ricardo Teixeira,
Nicolás Leoz and Julio Grondona."
Diese Aussage ist entscheidend,
wenn es um die Frage geht:
Gab es bei der Wahl von Katar
Korruption?
Korruption also bei der Katar-Wahl
laut Burzaco.
Zu dieser Zeit
war Sepp Blatter FIFA-Präsident.
Was sagt er heute dazu, dass laut
US-Akten drei Stimmen korrupt waren?
Ich habe nicht gewusst -
und weiss es heute noch nicht -,
wer alles von irgendwo Geld erhielt.
Ich kann nur sagen,
dass ich nie Geld erhalten habe.
Katar wurde
mit 8 zu 14 Stimmen gewählt.
Teixeira, Leoz, Grondona -
diese drei laut US-Justiz gekauften
Stimmen machten den Unterschied.
Wäre die Abstimmung
11 zu 11 ausgegangen,
hätte der damalige FIFA-Präsident
Blatter den Stichentscheid gehabt -
und Blatter hat die USA favorisiert.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass
drei Stimmen damals gekauft waren,
dann ist es so wie bei anderen
Parlamentsentscheidungen -
in Stadträten, Gemeinderäten -,
dann ist dieser Beschluss ungültig,
weil er eben auf kriminelle Art
und Weise zustande kam.
Und dann müsste dieser Beschluss
nach Anfechtung neu erfolgen,
zu anderen Bedingungen.
Dann müsste sich die FIFA
letztendlich überlegen:
"Was tun wir jetzt?"
Infantino weiss zu dieser Zeit:
In fünf Jahren
findet die WM in Katar statt.
Auf die brisanten Aussagen
der US-Justiz zum Stimmenkauf
reagiert er nicht.
Wir möchten von ihm wissen,
was er heute darüber denkt.
Unsere Anfrage für ein Interview
vor der Kamera lehnt er ab.
Wir bitten ihn um eine schriftliche
Stellungnahme - und warten.
Währenddessen erfahren wir:
FIFA-intern geben die
Burzaco-Aussagen sehr wohl zu reden.
Infantino hingegen reist um die Welt,
schüttelt Hände
und wirbt für seine neue FIFA.
The yellow card is a warning.
And when you want to kick out
someone, you show this one.
Die WM in Katar
rückt näher und näher.
Zürich, 5. Juni 2019,
Wahlkongress.
Es gibt nur einen Kandidaten:
Gianni Infantino.
Liebe Freunde, an diesem Wahltag
spricht niemand über Krise,
über Skandale, über Korruption.
Alles sei in bester Ordnung.
Ich bin stolz und glücklich,
dass die Reserven,
die bei meinem Amtsantritt
1 Mrd. betrugen,
heute bei 2,75 Mrd. sind,
also 1,75 Mrd. mehr.
Er wird per Akklamation
wiedergewählt.
Vielen Dank allen,
an meine Familie und Freunde,
an alle,
die mich lieben oder hassen.
Heute liebe ich alle.
Während Infantino
von Erfolg zu Erfolg eilt,
wird Michael Laubers Lage
immer kritischer.
Die Geheimtreffen
erweisen sich als fatal.
Dicke Post heute
für den Bundesanwalt Michael Lauber
vom Bundesstrafgericht in Bellinzona.
Er als Bundesanwalt, einer
seiner leitenden Staatsanwälte sowie
der Leiter des FIFA-Strafverfahrens
müssen in den Ausstand treten.
Damit stolpert Bundesanwalt Lauber
über seine inoffiziellen Treffen
mit FIFA-Präsident Gianni Infantino.
Lauber wird vom Bundesstrafgericht
als für befangen erklärt.
Er muss gewisse Verfahren abtreten,
gewisse Verfahren verjähren auch.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft scheint
die Orientierung verloren zu haben.
Die Schweizer Justiz
ist mit sich selbst beschäftigt.
Die Gerichtskommission
empfiehlt deshalb dem Parlament,
ihn nicht wiederzuwählen.
Die Bundesversammlung ist somit
verhandlungs- und beschlussfähig.
Es kommt anders:
Monsieur Michael Lauber
est réélu avec 129 voix.
* Applaus *
Es gibt ein Statement
und dann ist fertig. Eins.
Keine Nachfragen?
- Pas de français, pas de questions.
Guten Morgen.
- Könnten Sie etwas näher kommen?
Dann hören Sie mich alle,
wenn ich noch näher komme.
Ich freue mich
über diese Wiederwahl.
Ich bedanke mich beim Parlament
für sein Vertrauen.
Und ich bedanke mich auch bei
meinen Freunden und meiner Familie
für alles, was sie in dieser nicht
immer einfachen Zeit getan haben,
für ihre Unterstützung.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag.
Eine Nachfrage. Gestatten Sie ...
Währenddessen in der FIFA Zürich.
Dort passiert Erstaunliches:
Die FIFA-Ethikkommission
fällt ein Urteil,
das tiefgreifende Konsequenzen hat -
gestützt
auf den US-Kronzeugen Burzaco,
gestützt auf die US-Justiz.
Wir lesen im Urteil:
Das FIFA-Exekutivmitglied Teixeira
habe für seine Katar-Stimme
Schmiergelder erhalten.
Im Urteil wurde Burzacos Aussage,
die er in New York vor Gericht
machte, eins zu eins übernommen.
Mit anderen Worten: Im Urteil steht,
wer alles Bestechungsgelder
für Katar 2022 akzeptiert hat,
nämlich Leoz, Teixeira und Grondona.
Burzacos Aussage
wurde also eins zu eins übernommen
im Urteil der FIFA-Ethikkommission.
Warum stützt sich
die neue FIFA-Ethikkommission
unter Infantino auf die US-Akten
mit der Kronzeugenaussage?
Diese Frage bleibt unbeantwortet.
Wir sehen aber in den Unterlagen:
Die alte Ethikkommission unter Eckert
eröffnete bereits damals
im Zuge der Baur-au-Lac-Verhaftungen
das Verfahren gegen Teixeira.
Das Ethikkommissionsurteil
sorgt in Brasilien für Schlagzeilen.
A FIFA baniu o ex-presidente da CBF
Ricardo Teixeira por corrupção.
O ex-presidente da CBF
Ricardo Teixeira ...
O painel considerou Ricardo Teixeira
culpado de suborno
e o baniu para sempre de
atividades relacionadas ao futebol.
Die FIFA-Ethikkommission urteilt:
Teixeira wird wegen Korruption
lebenslänglich von allen
Fussballaktivitäten gesperrt.
Und sie verhängt eine Busse
von 1 Mio. Fr. -
also ungefähr gleich viel,
wie Teixeira laut US-Akten für seine
Katar-Stimme kassiert haben soll.
Teixeira ist der Einzige des Trios,
der noch lebt.
Leoz und Grondona sind verstorben.
Trotz dem klaren Urteil:
Teixeira behauptet nach wie vor,
nie Bestechungsgelder
akzeptiert zu haben.
Auf CNN Brasil gibt er Auskunft.
Warum ermittelt die US-Justiz
gegen Sie?
Weil Ricardo Teixeira
einer von denen war,
der die WM in den USA begraben hat.
Sie rächen sich.
Die WM, die in den USA
hätte stattfinden sollen?
Ja, sie rächen sich.
Sie wissen es.
(Hansjürg Zumstein)
Hätte Infantino damals nach diesem
Ethikkommissionsentscheid
nicht handeln müssen?
Die FIFA hätte sicherlich
eine Untersuchung
in Auftrag geben müssen,
ob und wie sich dieses Urteil
auswirkt auf die Vergabe an Katar.
Was sagt Infantino
zum brisanten Teixeira-Urteil?
Keine Reaktion,
keine öffentlichen Stellungnahmen.
Wir stehen drei Jahre
vor dem WM-Start in Katar.
Eines von zahlreichen Videos
aus dem Internet.
Für ihn haben
die Bauarbeiten in Katar Vorrang.
Es ist ein grossartiges Gefühl.
Und wenn man die Arbeit sieht,
wenn man die Schwingungen spürt -
das ist magisch.
Währenddessen im politischen Bern:
Die Geheimtreffen Infantino-Lauber
haben schwerwiegende Konsequenzen
für die Schweizer Justiz.
Die Aufsichtsbehörde kommt
zum Schluss, dass Michael Lauber
seine Amtspflichten
z.T. schwer verletzt hat.
Lauber zieht das Urteil weiter
ans Bundesverwaltungsgericht.
Wie wir heute wissen,
war das fatal für Lauber,
weil das Bundesverwaltungsgericht
auch zum Schluss kommt,
dass Lauber seine Pflicht
z.T. schwer verletzt hat
und -
das ist der entscheidende Punkt -
dass Michael Lauber vorsätzlich
die Unwahrheit über das
letzte Treffen erzählt haben soll.
Damit sagt das Gericht eigentlich,
er habe gelogen.
Nun geht er doch schneller
als gedacht:
Der in Ungnade gefallene
Bundesanwalt Michael Lauber
hat vorzeitig
auf Ende August gekündigt.
(Cornelia Bösch)
Nach seinem Rücktritt zieht sich
die Schlinge enger
um Noch-Bundesanwalt Lauber:
Der ausserordentliche Staatsanwalt
will gegen Lauber
ein Strafverfahren eröffnen
und beantragt
die Aufhebung seiner Immunität.
Herr Lauber, wie lief es?
- Schönen Tag.
Die Affäre Lauber ist für
die Schweizer Justiz ein Desaster.
Lauber ist noch nicht
aus dem Schneider.
Zwei ausserordentliche Bundesanwälte
ermitteln gegen ihn
sowie gegen Infantino.
Man darf gespannt sein,
ob sie herausfinden,
was beim letzten Geheimtreffen
diskutiert wurde.
Und sollte das Gericht
sogar zum Schluss gekommen,
dass Lauber
seine Position missbraucht hat,
um Infantinos Karriere zu fördern,
wäre das natürlich fatal.
Noch ist der Ausgang offen,
doch Infantino ist nicht zu stoppen.
Er stimmt in Katar WM-Helfer ein.
President Infantino,
the stage is yours.
I didn't hear you. Hello!
* Jubel *
You feel good?
Wir können der ganzen Welt zeigen,
dass Katar,
ja die ganze arabische Welt,
alle willkommen heisst
für ein unglaubliches Erlebnis.
Ihr seid das Herz,
die Seele und das Lächeln der WM.
Ich zähle "eins, zwei, drei"
und dann "Katar".
Eins, zwei, drei ...
- (Alle) ... Qatar!
Good.
And now: eins, zwei drei - and FIFA.
Eins, zwei ... Wait, wait!
Eins, zwei, drei ...
- (Alle) ... FIFA.
Wir wollen von der FIFA wissen:
Hat Teixeira
die 1 Mio. Fr. Busse bezahlt?
Die FIFA gibt auf diese Frage
keine Auskunft.
Aber wir realisieren: Im Hintergrund
laufen Gerichtsverfahren.
Denn Teixeira akzeptiert die Busse
und das Urteil
der FIFA-Ethikkommission nicht.
Er rekurriert
und zieht das Urteil weiter.
Wir verlangen bei den Gerichten
Einsicht in die Entscheide.
Und wir staunen erneut:
Das Verfahren hat jetzt Infantinos
Rechtsabteilung übernommen.
Sie verteidigt
den Standpunkt der Ethikkommission
vor dem obersten Gericht.
Es geht
zum Bundesgericht Lausanne ...
... und die FIFA gewinnt.
Das Bundesgericht
bestätigt im Februar dieses Jahres:
Teixeira ist der Korruption schuldig.
Mit anderen Worten:
Die FIFA anerkennt, dass
Burzacos Aussage glaubwürdig ist
und dass somit
rund um die Katar-Nomination 2022
mind. drei Stimmen korrupt waren.
Und wie die Situation jetzt ist,
ob und in welcher Form
die FIFA auf diese Entscheidung
des Bundesgerichts zu reagieren hat,
entscheidet Herr Infantino.
Was denken Sie?
- In dem Bereich denke ich nicht.
Nach monatelangem Warten
erhalten wir endliche
eine Mail von Gianni Infantino.
Viele Fragen bleiben unbeantwortet.
Zum Bundesgerichtsurteil
erhalten wir eine Zeile:
"Es gibt keinen Entscheid
der FIFA-Ethikkommission,
in dem von Bestechungsgeldern im
Zusammenhang mit Katar die Rede ist."
Infantinos Antwort
ist nachweislich falsch.
Mit seiner Antwort
widerspricht er erstens dem Urteil
der Ethikkommission gegen Teixeira
und zweitens
seinen eigenen Juristen.
Wie lautete Infantinos Motto
bei seiner Wahl zum FIFA-Präsidenten?
Es gibt zwei Optionen:
Entweder man versteckt sich
oder man stellt sich.
Man versteckt sich und wartet,
bis alles vorüber ist,
oder man stellt sich und handelt.
Für mich war Verstecken
nie eine Option,
ich wollte immer handeln.
Und ich fürchte mich nicht,
Verantwortung zu übernehmen
und voranzugehen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022